"
♪ ♪
WE ARE 29 DAYS BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS AND DEMOCRATS ARE IN A
FULL-BLOWN PANIC WHEN IT COMES
TO VOTERS CONCERNS OVER THEIR
TOP ISSUES, INFLATION IN THE
ECONOMY.
IT IS TYPICALLY NOT A GOOD SIGN
WHERE MODERATE CONGRESSWOMAN
THINKS WHAT HER WHAT REPORTING
NEEDS IS A COMPLETE OVERHAUL AND
BREAK AWAY FROM BIDEN'S DEEPLY
UNPOPULAR PRESIDENCY.
>> WE NEED A NEW GENERATION OF.
WE NEED NEW BLOOD PERIOD ACROSS
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I THINK THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN
SAYING THAT.
BUT IF THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES DECIDES TO
RUN, WE WILL SUPPORT IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: NO WONDER
DEMS ITCHING TO TOM BIDEN.
THE POLES HAVE BIDEN UNDER THE
WATER BY 15 POINTS ON AVERAGE IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
THE LIBERAL IS WARNING THE
PRESIDENT IS DRAGGING DOWN THE
PARTIES CANDIDATES.
>> I JUST THINK THE ECONOMIC
HEADWINDS ARE SO TOUGH.
AND BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE IT AS A
CANADA ANYMORE.
AND YOU REALLY CAN'T MAKE HIS
CASE.
I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
IN ANY BETTER PLACE.
>> Judge Jeanine: , TOP
DEMOCRATS SCENE SPOTTED SIPPING
WINE AND EATING HORS D'OEUVRES
AT A SWANKY FUND-RAISER IN
PARIS.
OKAY, SO, IT IS AMAZING NOW 29
DAYS OUT, DANA, COME BACK AND
FORTH, NOT SO FAST.
THEN McCONNELL WAS SHAKY.
NOW, HERE WE ARE, IT SEEMS
LIKE, THE LAST STAND AND
JOE BIDEN IS UNDERWATER IN 15 OF
THE DEMOCRAT BATTLEGROUND
STATES, SENATE CANDIDATES.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE SAYING, "WE NEED
NEW BLOOD" APPEARANCE BEFORE DO
YOU REMEMBER I THINK IT WAS
EARLY AUGUST, WE DID STORIES
ABOUT THE ARTICLES ALREADY
WRITTEN ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
COMEBACK.
HE WAS THE COMEBACK KID.
I WAS SKEPTICAL AT THE TIME, BUT
THERE IS ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT,
GOSH, MAY BE GAS PRICES ARE
STARTING TO TAKE DOWN.
WE HAVE THE KANSAS RESULT ABOUT
ABORTION ISSUE REFERENDUM EVEN
THOUGH THAT WAS BADLY WORDED AND
SEEMS LIKE IT GAVE HIM MOMENTUM.
THEY HAD SOME MONEY BEHIND THEM
AND REPUBLICANS BEATEN UP IN THE
PRIMARIES.
IT HAS TAKEN THEM A WHILE TO
CRAWL BACK.
WHAT HAS REALLY HELPED THEM AS
THE DEMOCRATS AND IT IS MOSTLY
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THIS AND SAVING MY
401(K) SUCKS RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
MATTER TO THEM WHEN THEY THINK
ABOUT OVERALL ECONOMIC PICTURE
APPEAR THEY ARE PAYING MORE FOR
GAS, GROCERIES AND THEN YOU HAVE
THE OPEC DECISION.
THAT WILL INCREASE PRICES EVEN
MORE.
SO I DON'T SEE AN ECONOMIC
MIRACLE HAPPENING FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE FOR A LONG TIME
SATING THE SPENDING PROPOSALS
THAT THE BIDEN TEAM WERE PUTTING
FORWARD WILL EXACERBATE
INFLATION.
THEY HAVE STUCK TO THAT MESSAGE
ONE, IT IS TRUE AND ALSO BECAUSE
IT WAS EFFECTIVE.
AND NOW PEOPLE ARE BEING ABLE TO
DRAW THOSE DIRECT LINES BETWEEN
ONE POLICY TO THE NEXT.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE IF THEY
DECIDE TO VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS
BELIEVE ALL OF A SUDDEN THINGS
WILL TURN AROUND.
BUT THEY DO THINK THE EXCESSIVE
SPENDING WILL HOPEFULLY COME TO
A STOP.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU
KNOW, JESSE, I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK INSTINCTIVELY LAW
AND ORDER, REPUBLICANS ARE
STRONGER.
WHAT YOU SEE NOW THAT THE COMING
OUT AND SAVING "WHETHER OR NOT
THEY HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SUPPORTING THEM IS
ANOTHER QUESTION."
BUT TERRY MORAN SAYS, "PEOPLE
DON'T WANT BIDEN AROUND.
HE CAN'T MAKE HIS CASE."
WHO HELPS THESE PEOPLE THAT IS
FRONT AND CENTER RIGHT NOW?
>> Jesse: TRY SELLING A HOUSE
THAT SOMEONE DIED IN.
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
IT'S BOOKS THE CUSTOMERS.
THAT IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW.
THESE APPROVAL RATINGS ARE
ABYSMAL.
BIDEN IS DOWN 18 UNDERWATER IN
ARIZONA.
MINUS 20 IN GEORGIA!
MINUS 17 IN NEVADA, MINUS 24
POINTS IN OHIO!
IT IS SO BAD.
HE IS A POLITICAL SKUNK.
IT IS LIKE NO MATTER HOW MANY
SHOWERS THE DEMOCRATS TAKE, THEY
CANNOT WATCH THE STINK OFF OF
THEM.
TRUMP, OBAMA, BUSH COME I
REMEMBER THEY US TO G OUT AND
BARNSTORM IN SEPTEMBER AND
OCTOBER.
THEY USED TO GO AROUND AND HOLD
UP THEIR HANDS "ALL RIGHT!"
HAVE YOU SEEN JOE BIDEN DO THAT
ONE TIME?
HAS JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY HOLD A
RALLY FOR AN ACTUAL CONTENDER
SINCE LABOR DAY?
NO!
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN ANY IMAGES LIKE
THAT.
I DARE YOU TO FACT-CHECK TO ME.
DOCTORS DON'T WANT HIM OUT THERE
EITHER.
HE CAN'T BE FLYING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
HE CAN'T DO TWO CONSECUTIVE DAYS
OF TRAVELING.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT WANTS HIM
TO CAMPAIGN FOR HIM AS STACEY
ABRAMS.
AND BIDEN IS NOT GOING TO
CAMPAIGN FOR HER BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T WANT TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH A LOSER.
HE EVEN KNOW SHE'S GOING DOWN.
>> Judge Jeanine: BY THE
WAY, DID YOU NOTICE STACEY
ABRAMS THAT SHE NEVER REALLY
DENIED...
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: IT IS SO BAD AND NOW
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LIKE, THEY
KEEP GETTING ASKED THE SAME
QUESTION: DO YOU WANT
JOE BIDEN -- FRESH BLOOD, THIS
IS WHAT FRESH BLOOD WAS ABOUT
PURITY OF JOE BIDEN APPROVAL
RATINGS AT 53%, NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT FRESH BLOOD.
THEY ARE GIVING JOE A
TRANSFUSION.
THEY LOVE JOE AND OTHER
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE YOUNG
LOOKING, THEY JUST WANT FRESH
BLOOD BECAUSE THEY WANT MORE
SENIORITY.
THEY WANT BIGGER, YOU
KNOW, POSITIONS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
THAT IS WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
>> Judge Jeanine: JESSICA, I
THINK YOU ARE CHOMPING AT THE
BIT.
>> Jessica: I THINK JESSE
USING A SKUNK WHICH I TAKE
PERSONALLY.
SO JOE BIDEN WAS OUT WITH JOHN
FETTERMAN, WHO IS IN ONE OF THE
CLOSEST RACES.
>> Jesse: LABOR DAY RALLY.
THE SPEED CHECKED.
>> Jesse: DID HE HOLD UP HIS
HAND LIKE THIS?
>> Jessica: I THINK
SO, ACTUALLY.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS LABOR DAY.
WAS THAT A MONTH AGO?
>> Jessica: OKAY, SO I THINK
CONGRESSWOMAN WAS TALKING ABOUT
MORE THAN JOE BIDEN IS THE
LEADERSHIP AND WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH NANCY PELOSI.
BECAUSE IN 2018, THERE WAS THIS
DIRECTION BY TIM RYAN WHERE THEY
DIDN'T WANT HER TO HAVE
SPEAKERSHIP AND MARSHA WAS GOING
TO RUN AGAINST HER.
THEY BROKE WITH THIS DEAL WHERE
SHE TERMINATED HERSELF.
AND DIDN'T SIGN ON IT AND
STENY HOYER, NANCY PELOSI SAID
SHE WAS A BRIDGE TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERSHIP.
I UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION NOT
JUST BECAUSE OF THE NUMBERS BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE
THAT HAVE WON HIGHLY COMPETITIVE
SWING DISTRICTS WITH INCREDIBLE
BACKGROUNDS.
IN 2018, WE HAVE THE CAMO WAVE
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE SERVED LIKE --
THEY GOT INTO OFFICE.
AND WHEN IS IT GOING TO BE -- IN
TERMS OF BIDEN APPROVAL RATING
WHEN YOU GO BACK IN HISTORY
2014, OBAMA WAS UNDERWATER.
THEY PICKED UP EIGHT IN TOTAL,
AND FIVE IN 2014.
THE NUMBERS WERE NOT AS BIG AS
17 POINTS, ET CETERA BUT IT DOES
NOT MEAN THE DEMOCRATS ARE DUMB
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE OBAMA HAD A
BASE CLINIC TRUMP HAD A BASE BUT
HE HAS NO BASE.
HE GOES TO A RALLY AND NO ONE IS
SHOWING UP.
>> Jessica: FIRST OF
ALL, BERNIE SANDERS HAD THE
BIGGEST RALLIES IN THE WORLD,
BIGGER THAN TRUMP IN A LOT OF
CASES IN THE DID NOT WIN.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN CLOSE TO A
SWING STATE AND DOES A RALLY AND
NO ONE IS SHOWING UP, JESSICA.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: DANA AND I
WOULD TALK ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, GREG, I LOVE
WHEN ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS BUDDY
PATRICK MALONEY GO TO PARIS AND
THEY GO TO GENEVA, SWITZERLAND.
THEY HAVE THESE FUND-RAISERS
ALLEGEDLY TO RAISE MONEY FROM
AMERICANS OVERSEAS?
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT?
>> Greg: I HAVE NO IDEA.
I FIND IT DISGUSTING.
IN TWO WORDS, JOE WAS IN A LOT
OF TROUBLE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE PERSON IN POWER WILL BE ON
THE DEFENSE, RIGHT, BECAUSE THEY
OWN -- THEY HAVE A RECORD AND
THEY OWN THE PRESENT.
ANOTHER TWO YEARS, THIS IS
PRETTY MUCH UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU HAVE SOARING CRIME RELATES
TO MIGRATES LIKE YOU HAVE NEVER
SEEN.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THIS IS
WORSE.
>> Greg: THERE IS NO BOTTOM TO
THIS.
WE HAVE SOARING INFLATION AND
JOE'S WORD, WE ARE APPROACHING
ARMAGEDDON.
THIS IS NOT COMFORTING.
THE HORSE HARSHEST CRITICS WOULD
NOT PREDICT THIS.
THE ACTUAL DEEDS ARE NOT TWEETS
OR PERSONALITY FLAWS, WHICH IS
ALL WE WERE TALKING ABOUT WHEN
TRUMP WAS AROUND.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE SELFISHNESS
THAT I'M SEEING.
YOU SEE PROMINENCE IN POLITICS
IN THE MEDIA WILL ADMIT BIDEN IS
OBJECTIVELY A TERRIBLE
PRESIDENT.
BUT THEY WILL STILL TAKE HIM
OVER TRUMP BECAUSE THEY ARE NO
LONGER STRESSED OUT, RIGHT?
SO THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE
EVERYBODY IN AMERICA SUFFERING
WITH CRIME AND INFLATION JUST SO
THEY COULD MAYBE 20 MINUTES MORE
OF SLEEP.
THAT IS THEIR SUFFERING.
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN BE NEAR TO
THAT IS IF THEY ARE FAR AWAY
WITH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, AND
THEY USUALLY ARE, THE MEDIA IS
FARAWAY AND ELITIST.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE POINT
ABOUT BLOOD, NEW BLOOD, MAYBE
SHE MEANT IT LITERALLY ACTUAL
TRANSFUSION OF PURE PLASMA AND
BLOOD MIGHT HELP HIM.
BUT IT DOES MATTER.
BECAUSE ROBERT WRIGHT AND THE
RIDER WENT SAID THE NUMBER OF
TIMES YOU SAY "SCREW IT"
INCREASES EXPONENTIALLY EVERY
DECADE.
YOU HAVE A GUY IN HIS NINTH
DECADE AND EVERY DAY IS A "SCREW
IT" DECADE.
HE LACKS INVESTMENT SO YOU TALK
ABOUT INFLATION OF GAS AND I'VE
SEEN IT ALL, HE AS HE GETS OLDER
CARES LESS BECAUSE THERE IS LESS
INVESTMENT.
HE WILL NOT BE AROUND LONGER.
THAT IS THE SCARY PART.
THAT IS WHY HE DOESN'T MOVE THE
OLD PEOPLE OUT OF THE WAY
SLOWLY.
YO